le problème des restaurants moi j'avais
un copain malheureusement dans un
fauteuil et j'ai découvert que comme les
toilettes étaient pas équipées mais ils
prenaient des cachets qui lui coupaient
leur envie de pisser
bonsoir bonsoir Bruno c'est donc acteur
musicien scénariste night clubber
tétraplégique depuis 7 ans donc
romancier
ici en 2001 pour cavalcade un bouquin
extraordinaire plein d'humour plein de
révélations sur la vie des handicapés
sur l'accident sur les suites tragiques
un bouquin extraordinaire qui s'est
vendu à 80 000 exemplaires et qui a été
traduit dans 10 pays et bientôt un film
oui avec avec Titeuf
qui va jouer votre enfin oui qui va
jouer oui oui et réalisé par type Suissa
et produit par Patrick Goldman
alors le problème c'est que avec tout
cet argent vos allocations ont été
supprimées non
on touche plus de 40 000 francs par an
enfin je sais plus combien ça fait en
euros
il vous enlève les allocations et de
toute façon on peut pas vivre enfin le
le
comment dire le les allocations qu'on
vous donne par mois ça suffit pas pour
vivre donc il faut vraiment trouver
c'est ça c'est que vous dites il me
reste 30 ans voilà à peu près comment je
vais faire si parce que vous êtes
toujours besoin maintenant d'avoir
quelqu'un pour s'occuper de vous trois
personnes par mois
il faut les payer voilà donc c'est ce
qui coûte le plus cher enfin moi ça va
je m'en sors je pense surtout à
aux ados aux enfants à tous ceux que
j'ai rencontré à Garches
et
à tous les gens enfin tous les tous ces
gamins dont les familles peuvent pas
aider financièrement qui se retrouvent
dans des centres eux c'est vraiment un
problème
mais enfin c'est en train de changer là
j'ai vu que qu'ils étaient en train de
se remuer au niveau des ministères et il
serait temps que ça bouge militaire un
peu je m'y mets oui bien sûr parce que
c'est quelque chose qui me touche et
puis depuis cavalcade j'ai eu plein de
lettres d'associations plein de
témoignages plein de courrier plein de
gens que j'ai rencontrés et en fait on
est six millions d'invalides en France
énorme et 35 millions en Europe donc
c'est une force vigoureuse c'est des
gens qui votent et que c'est vrai qu'en
France on est vraiment en retard par
rapport aux pays anglo-saxons par
rapport aux États-Unis
les États-Unis ils ont eu la carte du
Vietnam donc ils ont eu une population
énorme d'invalides et en France on est
vraiment en retard quoi tous les jours
c'est une bataille ce serait quoi les
mesures les plus urgentes à prendre
aujourd'hui pour les handicapés tous les
accès parce qu'il y a tous les jours et
je le vois
c'est vraiment du boulot moi je vous
conseille la lecture de cavalcade qu'un
bouquin avec beaucoup de beaucoup
d'humour beaucoup de distance surtout ça
et puis en même temps des trucs
terribles comme le gang des ciseaux
ah oui qui va être très présent dans le
film d'ailleurs avec des jeunes
cascadeurs et qui a beaucoup surpris les
gens mais
c'est vrai que quand on voit un quand
voit une clinique enfin un hôpital comme
gars qui est énorme il y a 2000
personnes tous les jours c'est vraiment
une cité dans la cité et
ses gamins ils ont 12 13 14 ans ils sont
abandonnés par leur famille par leurs
parents à l'hôpital tout s'arrête à 4h
donc les gamins ils sont livrés
eux-mêmes donc faut passer tenir après
qu'ils aient envie de s'amuser ou de
prendre des risques en coupant des gens
sont insensibilisés donc avec des
ciseaux et des jeux de oui des jeux de
douleur
contre même et puis contre les gens qui
leur viennent pas et à côté de ça ils
étaient très émouvants très
irraisonné en bloc en groupe en gang il
protégeait ceux qui veulent c'est ça qui
est très violent puis aussi des choses
extraordinaires dans cavalcade c'est
quand vos amis décident de vous faire
retrouver une vie sexuelle en vous
envoyant une bombasse un porte-avion
enfin c'est ce bouquin vraiment et je le
conseille vraiment à tout le monde et là
vous revenez quand même alors là
maintenant c'est un roman qui s'appelle
le châtiment de Narcisse c'est publié
chez Robert Laffont alors le pitch c'est
très simple c'est l'histoire d'un homme
à qui il reste 100 jours à vivre voilà
il a une jeune homme
qui est un roi de l'événementiel qui a
un peu le roi de la fête mais qui est
assez malancolique donc qui est un peu
comment dire ambivalent avec son
caractère et puis qu'au cours d'une nuit
une fête de trop il fait une rencontre
étrange dans la nuit une jeune fille qui
s'appelle écho qui a 11 ans qui est un
peu mystérieuse et qui lui annonce qu'il
lui reste plus que 100 jours à vivre et
lui évidemment il pense que c'est il est
face à sa mémoire et pense que c'est un
que c'est un gag il prend pas au sérieux
elle va revenir voilà et donc il y a un
twist final que je me garderai bien de
de révéler mais un épilogue oui parce
que à 100 jours donc 100 jours c'est 14
semaines c'est trois mois
donc en fait il a 100 jours pour trouver
la vérité
trouver la source savoir qui lui en veut
pour qu'on veut sa mort et puis la 100
jours pour essayer de sauver sa peau et
de savoir jusqu'où il est prêt à aller
peut-être même prêt à tuer pour sauver
sa peau une vie contre la sienne c'est
un livre assez passionnant c'est
terrible ce que je vais dire mais
l'accident dont vous avez été victime
nous a permis de découvrir un écrivain
quoi je pense honnêtement si vous aviez
pas eu cet accident vous auriez continué
à faire le con la nuit à écrire des à
écrire des scénars et voilà quoi oui ça
m'a enfin
j'avais pas trop le choix c'est à dire
que après l'hôpital je me suis posé la
question de savoir ce que vous allez
faire de ma vie donc j'avais trois
choses dans les mains j'avais la musique
bon c'était un peu compromis que les
mains le métier de comédien bon j'ai
déjà tourné on me propose que des
recommences
que des rôles marrants de flic en
fauteuil qui sont pris de mal de trop ça
je suis ravi je et puis l'écriture mais
l'écriture je la faisais en tant que
dilettante sur des sites comme sur des
chansons qui me servaient pour moi pour
mon métier de chanteur de comédien et
l'écriture c'est un vrai métier donc
aujourd'hui je peux organiser toute ma
vie autour de l'écriture et donc c'est
devenu une vraie raison de vie de vivre
et puis une jubilation même temps en
même temps une souffrance parce que le
matin il faut y aller faut se mettre
devant la feuille blanche et l'avantage
de la littérature c'est que quoi qu'il
vous arrive on peut en faire un livre ça
transcende tout l'écriture c'est quelle
que soit les les malheurs que la vie
vous réserve vous pouvez toujours en
faire un livre c'est la c'est la force
de la littérature oui puis après la vie
des autres parce qu'on est des grands
sampleurs il y a toujours ce débat à
Paris de des romans de l'autofiction
mais on chope tous qu'on entend à la
télé à la radio dans les livres dans les
magazines dans les quotidiens
et puis c'est ça le rôle de l'auteur de
l'écrivain c'est s'approprier des vies
qui ne parviennent pas et en faire en
faire des grands moments des moments
d'émotion des moments un livre c'est ça
c'est chapitre en chapitre de rire de
pleurer de
tenir le tenir le choc pendant 300 350
pages ça vous avez une profondeur c'est
l'histoire finalement non oui et je me
demandais ce que tu penses que tu vas
remarcher un jour quand on voit
maintenant
c'est ça ouais ils annoncent toujours
des choses moi je me tiens un peu au
fait et sur les laboratoires aux
États-Unis un peu partout
et à la fin du sujet ils disent mais bon
pas voilà et puis c'est toujours des
souris et les sourires elles parlent pas
ils disent pas
si elle marche ou pas il va être la
différence la recherche mais c'est vrai
que c'est aussi une question de pognon
et que ce serait bien d'avoir une soirée
ça j'aimerais bien ça d'avoir une soirée
telle Téléthon il y a des choses très
très bien il y a les Restos du Coeur ce
serait bien d'avoir une soirée avec des
artistes avec Jamel avec
de faire une soirée pour la recherche
sur la moelle épinière va tout ce qui
tourne autour de la malpinière les gens
en fauteuil et puis tout ce qui tout ce
qui tourne autour de la recherche
médullaire ça se sera vachement
écoute très volontiers moi je trouve si
la télé peut servir à quelque chose
c'est pas plus mal tu sais bien
[Applaudissements]
depuis trois ans vous avez gagné en
mobilité en motricité non c'est assez
non je pense que j'ai chaud au maximum
de mes capacités physiques donc on
apprend à habiter un nouveau corps c'est
assez étonnant donc il y a il y a des
choses oui des petits miracles enfin des
petits trucs comme ça au jour le
jour le jour mais six mois après dans
l'eau dans des situations allongées des
petites des petits miracles donc ça
c'est toujours ça de gagner
tu vois lui alors voilà tout à l'heure
elle nous expliquait qu'elle aimait pas
son corps que si que là tu te rends
compte non j'ai pas dit que j'aimais pas
mon corps mais c'est que c'est un
rapport particulier mais lui aussi il
est dans une problématique toujours du
corps comment comment il a envie
ça se place ailleurs mais il est aussi
là dedans c'est à dire qu'est-ce qu'il
en fait comment on l'appelle
alors vous travaillez dur aussi sur les
destins brisés du rock ça intéressant
aussi dire que votre accident vous a
amené à vous intéresser au destin de
j'étais rockeur avant
c'est
andrexiste ceux qui sont morts
jeunes quoi
c'est vraiment la loi du rock ça où
Elvis qui est mort un peu plus tard mais
Elvis il est mort comme disait Lennon il
est mort quand il est parti à l'armée
quoi en 56
il y a Christophe qui a dit le rock n'
roll s'est arrêté en 59 quand on a
supprimé l'aileron à l'arrière de la
Cadillac c'est une phrase intéressante
alors vos plaisirs aujourd'hui c'est
quoi la piscine c'est un vrai plaisir
parce que vous dites c'est le seul
endroit où je peux danser avec une fille
oui je pète debout dans l'eau
humeur il y a pas de souci vous avez vu
tout à l'heure les deux petites chiottes
là qui m'ont porté là c'était super
sympa donc
il faut pas avoir peur de sourire
d'aller vers les gens les gens ils sont
de communiquer parce qu'on a très peur
des fauteuils ont communique pas du tout
avec eux et quand on le fait on se rend
compte qu'on apprend des choses
incroyables sur leur ville tous les
jours justement le problème des
restaurants moi j'ai un copain
malheureusement dans un fauteuil et j'ai
découvert que comme les toilettes
étaient pas équipées mais ils prenaient
des cachets qui lui coupaient envie de
pisser et et que des trucs comme ça que
nous on n'est pas du tout au courant et
quand je suis venu de voir au théâtre
Laurent c'était c'était costaud hein
le minimum pour Laurent et mais c'est
marrant parce que il y a pas il y a 20
personnes qui m'ont porté
comme un yoyo tu vois il t'amène
jusqu'au premier rang c'est bien et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu